even in this idyllic setting there's no
reprieve from the crises these leaders
face as they put a mangrove forest in
Denpasar away from the formality of the
G20 Summit itself a chance for
reflection and quiet conversations on
more pressing matters far from Bali and
the moment when the world had came
together at the G20
to urge de-escalation
Russia continues to uh has chosen
Escalade in Ukraine while we're meeting
earlier the U.S president called an
emergency meeting after two people were
killed in explosions in Poland overnight
near the border with Ukraine he was
joined by leaders from Japan and NATO
countries a defense Alliance which also
includes Poland I'm going to make sure
we figure out exactly what happened he
also said preliminary findings suggested
that missile was not fired from Russia
even in the absence of the Russian
president the war in Ukraine has
overshadowed the leaders Summit taking
Focus away from issues on the official
agenda like healthcare and renewable
energy the leader's declaration issued
at the end of The Summit said most
members strongly condemned the war in
Ukraine and stressed it is causing
immense human suffering hurting growth
increasing inflation and heightening
food shortages
it also called for the continuation of a
deal set to expire this week which
allows grain-blocked at Ukrainian ports
by Russian ships to be exported
the issuing of a declaration in this
context was hailed as an achievement for
Indonesian diplomacy the communique that
was released today is substantive it's
comprehensive it's action-oriented and
it was by no means assured and I think
the president and his team deserve
enormous praise for the leadership that
they've demonstrated over the year but
especially over the past few days
the host said goodbye to his
high-profile visitors perhaps relieved
the summit was more successful than many
had expected Jessica Washington Al
Jazeera Bali